anyway here with the very latest is
house Judiciary Committee chairman Jim
Jordan Congressman sorry to ask the
selfish question first but um I feel my
privacy has already been invaded it's
why I've not had an email account for
years and years and years cuz you know
right it seems like you know the
government's perfectly fine releasing my
private text messages with Paul maniford
my private text messages with uh people
that work for the government uh my
private text messages on January 6th um
so I don't really have privacy how were
they trying to they were censoring me
our government was involved in this do I
have any recourse for this legal we
we've introduced legislation senator
Paul and I that would give you some
recourse and would hold these people
accountable so that that that's a
legislative Remy that we're pursuing but
here's the here's the real takeaway the
censorship industrial complex was bigger
than we thought it wasn't just big
government working with big Tech to
limit your speech and limmit Twitter or
tweets and post on Facebook it was big
government big universities and big Tech
all working together to limit speech and
it was disproportionately as you listed
off all those conservatives
disproportionately targeting
conservatives Molly Hemingway Shan
Hannity president Trump members of
Congress you can go down the list that's
who they went after and here's the
kicker it was all true stuff or some
cases it was satire it was a joke but it
was all true and yet they went after it
uh in this organized fashion where they
live Li mited how the the reach it would
have the visibility filtering they did
and they took things down that's how
egregious this was all right let me ask
you about Weiss that you had an
opportunity to grill today because the
we learned from the IRS whistleblowers
and they took contemporaneous notes that
Mr Weiss said he had no power to bring
any charges investigative charges to
Hunter Biden in jurisdictions outside of
his own now correct me if I'm wrong
didn't Mr Weiss and didn't Merrick
Garland testify to just the
opposite yeah mayor Garland said he had
ultimate Authority in fact David Weiss
this summer told us three different
things in a 33-day uh time period June
7th he writes me and says I have
ultimate authority to determine when
where and whether to bring charges June
30th he writes me again and says well no
actually I don't my authority is limited
to my us attorney's District the
District of Delaware and then July 10th
he writes Lindsey Graham the ranking
member on the Senate Judiciary committee
and says well I've not sought special
counsel Authority but I've had
discussions with the Department of
Justice now today under oath he said
something different because he was
directly asked did you ever seek special
attorney status and his response was yes
as I pointed out earlier today yes in
the spring of 2022 so he sought it but
was never actually given that and yet he
maintained somehow that oh I still had
the authority even though I asked for it
and even though they never gave it to me
somehow he still had it so his story
doesn't stack up but the guy's story who
does hold true and has never wavered is
Gary shapley and Mr Ziggler the
whistleblowers and everything we learned
today further confirms what Mr shapley
and Mr Ziggler have come forward and
told us and remember sh they stood up to
a couple hours of cross-examination from
Democrats in the oversight committee and
again their story has checked out with
every witness that we've deposed okay so
that means that before Congress one side
lied and one side told the truth both
sides can't be telling the truth now I
tend to believe the whistleblowers uh
the ones that took contemporaneous notes
uh and I tend not to believe uh the
people that we know that have been
active and involved in protecting all
things Biden family so yeah I thought if
you lied before Congress you can get
arrested for that and be charged for
that am I wrong yeah you can it's tough
to prove but it sure looks like maritt
Garland Miss lettuce I think David Weiss
certainly missed lettuce with his
initial response to me on June 7th this
summer because that changed as I said in
a one- Monon time period and what he
said today didn't back up what he told
us in those letters uh this summer when
will we get the transcribed interview in
full in a couple days it'll be ready in
a couple days and we will make that
available uh so people can he there's a
lot of questions he wouldn't answer he
stuck to this issue of authority but
there was a lot of questions where he
just didn't answer so there's going to
be a lot of that transcript but where he
did I think it it totally confirmed
other witnesses that we've talked to and
of course what Mr chapley and Mr Ziggler
have testified to their story has never
wavered their testimony has never
changed the White House has changed
multiple times about this investigation
and of course the justice department has
changed their story multiple times as
well now my understanding is you both
you and chairman J uh comr and chairman
and and others uh are we getting near
the point where Biden family members now
will be subpoenaed and if so what Biden
family members are we looking at and why
did the White House say today that the
the 200,000 loan repayment from Joe's
brother uh that they're not going to
provide documentation that's what
they're saying uh that proves that Joe
actually gave a loan that had to be
repaid uh I would think that would be
easier to produce wouldn't you you would
think so maybe they don't have it who
knows why they're doing that but that's
consistent with with with the White
House so there are a number of people we
want to talk to we want to talk to
Hunter Biden's other business partners
wob Walker Mr shman we want to talk to
them we want to talk to James Biden
Hunter Biden we want to talk to the guy
who stepped forward and paid Hunter tax
Hunter Biden's taxes uh just you know
out of the goodness of his heart stepped
forward and paid several million dollars
in taxes that Hunter B node we want to
talk to that individual we want to talk
to some of the folks who bought Hunter
Biden's art we think that's important
for us to to get into so those subpoenas
will be coming some of those will start
I believe as early as Wednesday
Wednesday uh Thursday of this week do
you have any doubt that Joe Biden was
active in these business deals do you
have any doubt that Joe Biden lied about
uh what he knew uh do you have any doubt
that Joe Biden himself benefited
financially do you have any doubt that
Joe Biden took specific actions when he
was vice president that benefited his
family members which would be the very
definition of the bribery Statute in
this country well there's no doubt that
he told us things that were not accurate
he said he was never at dinners never
talked to Hunter Biden's business
partners never talked to the people
Hunter Biden and his and his team were
doing business with we know that is
false we had that from Deon archer in a
in a deposition so we know that is false
and we know that Joe Biden specifically
weighed in relative to barisma and the
executives who were under pressure after
he gets a call from his son and just a
few days later goes to keev and and
starts the process of firing the
prosecutor so we know that all happened
relative to barisma and and Ukraine um
so there Sur looks like they told us
things that again were not truthful all
right Jim Jordan thank you we appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else